[Musique]
dans le collège et plus de 800 élèves
étaient présents pour le challenge
sportif départemental des collèges et
pour les encadrer les listes des
enseignants de sports sous leurs
chapeaux de compétition
[Musique]
droit au sport doit être consacré les
graver dans le marbre
au même titre que le droit à l'éducation
et la santé
le parrain c'est comment daffreville la
marraine ctt actes qui sont là et voilà
quoi je suis sûr et certain que parmi
tous ces jeunes là et on aura un ou des
mêmes plus j'espère qu'il sera un jour
qui pourra fuir les flambeaux de la
réunion
[Musique]
dizaine d'épreuves permettait de
départager ces établissements qui
croient dans les valeurs du sport
escalade course en relais lutte vtt pont
de singe tir à la corde ou encore tir à
l'arc un moment de fête avec en ligne de
mire génération 2024
ces anneaux olympiques
en porte des valeurs comme l'excellence
l'amitié le respect et l ont fortement
inspiré les jeunes qui en peu de temps
remonter les productions que vous voyez
derrière qui sont de qualité et il est
difficile de choisir pour établir un
classement entre chacune d'entre elles
vraiment l'objectif c'est d'amener les
jeunes à la pratique sportive pour qu'il
réussisse sa scolarité
le département accompagne toute l'année
la structuration de l'urss académique
mais aussi chaque association sportive
de collège
entourés de leurs copains l'engagement
est palpable car ici le collectif porte
chacun d'eux on fait de l'art de l'iaaf
on fait du sport par exemple après midi
ou sur le samedi ça nous évite de rester
à la maison regarder la télé souliers on
va pas à l'école sont motivés c'est ce
que je retiens
il y a de l'enthousiasmé département
vous ont aussi un voyage à l'île maurice
des jeux d'asie de l'est samedi on a pas
tous les moyens de ce licencié dans un
club on apprenait tout le temps les
parents sont pas forcément disponibles
et l'une est celle qui permet justement
d'accéder plus facilement aux sports
nature et aux compétitions
l'arrivée de ces jeunes représentent
l'avenir l'avenir de la région l'avenir
de notre pays
ce sont des sur les citoyens il faut en
train de se préparer comme en voiture et
je suis content qu'ils aient compris les
valeurs du sport le sport c'est la santé
c'est ça donne confiance en soi c'est un
thème aussi de bien réussir vos études
cinq ans a les yeux chaque jour hors du
temps scolaire nous enfants grandissent
par cette pratique sportive initiée par
l'urss
[Musique]